[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to cotton
under the covers under the hood we've
called it many many names we'll call it
this one right now we want to look at
the way some of the futures in Colin
work I'm Chet Haase and I'm all Maggie
and let's do this thing
yeah and we gave this talk before or
like a few weeks ago in France the
difference is today we have people from
JetBrains in the audience so a polygon I
said something very stupid so feel free
to yell at us it's fine
yeah so we'll see if we were actually
correct when we wrote the talks so Colin
very awesome language very cool lots of
interesting features you're doing it
again
you're taking my slide are you gonna go
Chet has this issue in the speaker notes
right here it says my name and he starts
talking and he keeps telling my slide
every time all right
so cartoon is awesome who's using cut in
here all right so we don't really have
to convince you that cutting is great
but just in case it's concise you have
less boilerplate you get powerful
extension libraries we write our own
there's a bunch of Android X or jetpack
extension libraries for various api is
platform or not fully compatible with
the java programming language and
therefore the android api s which makes
it very easy for you to adapt in your
application and it has a lot of modern
language features like co-routines check
what our core routines things alright
and it's always evolving but some of
these magical things in Kotlin really
are magical and mysterious how do those
things work especially since we're
compiling down to the same byte code
that runs other languages that don't
have these features so how does that
stuff work so that's the whole point of
the talk take a look on the inside and
see what's going on we're gonna take a
look at two different things right now
today we're going to look at how these
things work and we're also going to show
you some tools to use to get this
information basically the tools that we
use to discover this stuff we're not
going to do it in that order we're going
to do it in this order instead so first
we'll talk about the tools and then
we'll talk about the features so tools
alright so there are two tools you can
use the first one is looking at the
cutting byte code there's a special tool
for that in IntelliJ and Android studio
and the second one part of the same tool
is you can convert the byte code back to
the Java programming language which
sometimes is very helpful to understand
what's going on so you don't have to
decipher byte code yourself finally the
memory profiler so not about the byte
code itself but sometimes you know some
of those languages features may create
allocations which may or may not matter
depending on what you're doing what kind
of code you're writing which is a useful
tool to know about in general not just
in the context of this talk so here's an
example primitive types are handled a
little bit differently so in cutting
when you say this VAR i 0 equals 5
obviously you'd occurring in int so
capital I ain't it's not knowable so it
cannot be no and it's equivalent to the
lower case in the Java programming
language so it is still a primitive type
now if you specify the type yourself
same thing it's an int it's a primitive
type in the java programming language
but if you declare it as knowable the
only way we can handle that with the
current runtimes
is that it has to become the in question
mark type in Catalan which becomes the
capital I integer type in the Java
programming language and certainly it's
not a primitive type anymore it's a
full-blown
object and this can have consequences so
how do we find out stuff like that as
well as he said one of the ways that we
can do that is by looking at byte code
so let's look at some now
that's pretty self-explanatory
so let's move on to something else so in
IntelliJ there are different ways to
look at byte code but fortunately we
have tools integrated directly into
Android studio into the IDE if you go up
in the menu you can say yeah show me
that byte code and then you get this
viewer over here so if you look
carefully in the editor on the left
you'll see that the cursor is on a
particular line of code and then it
highlights the equivalent byte code on
the right to show you what's going on
some of the information in the byte code
it gets a little noisy in there there's
metadata to tell you what line that's
associated with a little extra
information but there's a couple of
instructions in particular which are the
actual byte code instructions so for the
stuff oh yeah then then there's another
way of doing this on the command line
you can use Java P instead and that will
spit out a file you can take a look at
nicely formatted bytecode different way
to do it that's not integrated into the
IDE so for the code that we're looking
at before you have this far Iza we
haven't told it it's going to use type
inference but it's set to be this
integer value so what's going on we have
a little bit of metadata about the line
numbers and then it says byte push of
the value of 25 so it's going to take
that value of 25 extend it to an integer
push it onto the stack then it's gonna
pull it back off the stack and it's
gonna store an integer into the first
variable so integer store and then we go
on the second line we're not using type
inference we've actually said no no we
want you to be an int we're gonna assign
you the value 78 same thing happens
we're gonna push a 78 extend it to an
integer onto the stack we're going to
pull that off store it into the second
integer variable and then for the third
case where we have is knowable type
we've got got I - that's going to be a
nullable int of the value of 14 first
step is going to be the same we're gonna
push byte extended integer
onto the stack but then we're gonna call
a method we're gonna call integer value
of which looks like this it takes in an
int a primitive int type and it returns
an integer so in the middle of that it's
going to box it into an integer type
creating that object on the fly and then
return the integer type and then instead
of storing an integer into a variable
it's going to store a reference to the
object that we've curry
so if you don't enjoy reading bytecode
it's really not that complicated doing
it again what's that my name on the
speaker notes that's why I was
introducing you my mouse I'm gonna tell
you what to do
keep going you started it so if you
don't want to read all of that bytecode
it's actually pretty straightforward
there's some simple reference Docs out
there that you can take a look at you're
pushing your pop in your setting but if
you don't want to deal with that there
is an easier way especially a more
concise way to see what's actually going
on and for that you would use the byte
code you want me to keep going all right
rest of the presentation is mine here we
go I'll stop over there
what's that I'll be over there all right
so let's say you've got this code could
you go a little bit further actually so
you've got this code you have the byte
code representation over there and if
you look at the top of that window
you've got this button that says
decompile so you click on that thing and
then you'll in your editor window you'll
be shown some some java programming
language code that looks more like this
right so you got the byte code fairly
verbose all the things going on you know
each of the lines of Kotlin code may
expand to several lines about byte code
along with the metadata or you can see
this fairly terse Java code instead you
see basically straightforward things
going on there you have some int values
you have some integer values that got
Auto boxed and then we're printing out
the values there just like that you want
to talk about the memory profile where
it says you'll name it does I'm going to
talk about the memory profile where
there the third approach that we have
using the tools to find out what's going
on is to actually see what's going on
with allocations and collections in the
system so one of my favorite tools when
I joined the team and for many years
after that was oh is this proof I'm
gonna tweet that
[Laughter]
allocation tracker allocation tracker
was a tool that you would run in DDMS
and you would start it at some point in
time and you would use the app for a
while and then you would stop it and it
would say here are all the objects that
were allocated on the fly and then you
could click on any of those instances
and it would show you the call stack
really powerful really useful wasn't
integrated in with any of the rest of
the tools so kind of a pain to get to a
lot of people didn't even know it was
there because actually finding it was a
little bit tricky so now we have memory
profiling directly integrated into the
ID with the rest of the profilers that
have come online in studio in the last
few years so this also allows you to
track memory usage over time you can see
how big the keep is at any given time
you can see when garbage collections
happen and what happened because of
those and you can catch leaks which is
really powerful this is another thing
that yes we allowed you to do it on
Android but oh man did we require you to
jump through a lot of Hoops a lot of
heaps you would you know dump a heap and
you would transcode that into a
different format you would use some
external tool and then you walk through
this amazingly complex set of
information now all of that stuff is
integrated directly and in the ID and
after all of this it allows you to track
allocations and that's what we care
about today so I wrote this code all by
myself really simple thing we've got
this nullable int value you've got a
tight loop in there in the method we're
going G Rho to 10,000 so 10,000 and 1
times it's going to whip through the
loop and it's going to set we know that
that's going to end up being a capital I
integer value set from the primitive I
loop value that we've got so we can
click on this in the lower left of the
IDE you've got this little
toolbar of little tools you can run if
you click on the profiler
you'll get something that looks like
this it shows you all the profilers that
we currently offer you've got CPU you
got the memory that woke into you've got
networking and you give out battery
power usage so if you click on the
memory one it expands to take over the
whole screen there and you can see heap
usage over time now what we really care
about here is what happened there right
I don't care when it's not changing what
I care is what caused it to actually
bump up
and keep usage and why was that so you
can drag the cursor along there you can
select this window of time to see what's
going on and just like allocation
tracker you can see all of the things
that were allocated down below and you
can see that in fact there are a bunch
of capital I integers they got allocated
in fact there are exactly nine thousand
eight hundred and seventy-three which is
weird we're in a loop going through ten
thousand and one times why do we not
have ten thousand and one allocations
going on so there's the loop and that
for some reason didn't equal ten
thousand and one allocations and it's
because of the value of more
particularly because of this caching
logic that we have when the run time
starts up it knows that most
applications are going to need some
manager values and so it caches values
from negative 128 up to 127 puts them in
a cache and now when everybody anybody
asks for a value of for one of those
it's just gonna return that it's already
been created as not integer it's not
being boxed and allocated on the fly
which means the only values that are
going to be allocator are outside of
that region which turns out ten thousand
and one minus 128 is going to be nine
thousand 873 has nothing to do with this
talk I thought it was interesting so the
one that we care about are the capital I
integer allocations so we're going to
click on that and that brings up another
window that shows each of those
individual allocations when they happen
in what was going on we can click on one
of those and just like allocation
tracker it pops up the call stack and
from that we determined that in fact
that was being allocated because of the
boxing operation that was happening in
that tight loop let's talk about
language feature
I appreciate this thank you for the
cheers but maybe you wait until the end
do you mind if I take this one yeah I do
actually
I can just leave if you want anyway
enums
your favorite topic so please using them
but we're going to talk about them
anyway so here's an enum our roads all
by myself as well called blend mode we
have some values doesn't really matter
what they are in here I'm how I'm using
the UNAM I'm using a when statement and
effectively the equivalent of a switch
in the Java programming language and for
every value of genome I call function
that doesn't remember what we do what's
interesting is what happens when we look
at the jarred byte code so here's what
it looks like the first thing it does is
called this this gets tagged static up
code it accesses a interest so that's
the square bracket with the capital I at
the end so it's a field in a class
called bling link $80 when mappings dot
dollar enum switch mapping dollar zero I
never wrote a class called code this in
my code but there it is
and then what's interesting is after it
gets disarray it invokes the ordinal
method on the in value itself and then
it does an eye a load so I allowed text
the output of the ordinal method call
and then use that as an index in the
array that we just fetched so and
finally does the actual switch so it
doesn't switch on the enum value itself
it first goes through another array and
intermediate array and we're gonna look
at what this already looks like and then
that's our code so here's what the code
what the jury could looks like so what
is interesting here is that this is not
specific to cut in the java programming
language compiler will also do the same
thing but you know it's still
interesting to look at it so the code
that gets generated is this there's this
special mapping class that contains an
array that has the same length as the
number of enums that you're Indian
values that we have in the ingham
classic to declare and then in the
static initialization code this array is
populated with the values of genomes and
some special constants generated by the
compiler so what happens if we create
another method in our code that does
another when on the enum so we do a when
in the same order we we switch over all
the
of Jinan if we go back to the giant
class we can see there's a second array
that was generated and also populated
with enum values and some magic
constants by the compiler and actually
you can see that those two arrays are
exactly the same they are the same
length and they contain exactly the same
mappings but if we generate if we used
in once again in a when and this time we
used we declare the enum values in a
different order and we look at the
generate code we have a third array as
expected also the same length but the
mappings are different I believe the
reason the compilers do this is that if
you change the enum the code that that
was compiled before with the old version
of genome will still work so they need
this indirection
but what becomes interesting is
obviously most of the time you will
never need to care about this if you
have a lot of wounds on enums in
performance-critical code you're gonna
have extra code that gets initialized
that runs at initialization time and you
have this extra help in memory but most
of the time you don't need to care about
this usiness
all right let's talk about laziness I
know a lot about this very common
pattern in software to say I may need to
allocate this thing but it's gonna cause
a lot of work and maybe I don't want
those allocations in the background work
to to happen to do that because maybe
the code won't need it so we'll we'll do
it lazily we'll do it sometime later
right so manual approach looks like this
so caveat really stupid example nobody
should ever do this just to avoid
allocating and no matter how it's
implemented on a very stupid example it
is a very stupid example there is a very
real example that is almost as stupid
which is code that we actually saw which
I which did lazy allocation for a rect
object which is just four times less
stupid than this right so allocating for
integers but for some reason they wanted
to do it lazily because why allocate if
you don't need to write so bear with me
so we have this inch we're gonna set it
equal to 573 but maybe nobody's gonna
need this so we're gonna make it lazy
instead so we're gonna have a private
member variable that's knowable now part
of the problem here is we know from the
earlier example is well now we have
something that could have been a
primitive but now all of a sudden we've
made it an object type instead just
because we want to set it to no but
anyway you've got this private member
variable
and then you have the actual thing that
they're gonna access and you say okay
when they actually call the getter we'll
see if it's null and that's the trigger
to say okay now actually set the value
to this thing and return the value and
you're done next time they ask for it's
already allocated and set and you don't
have to worry about it that's the
general approach I'm sure we've all done
this hundreds of times hopefully for a
less stupid examples than this one all
right this is what it looks like at Java
level like this is essentially what it
compiles to if we look at the decompiled
bytecode it looks exactly as what you
would expect it to you've got the same
thing going on
with in some integers and it's doing the
right thing there okay but there's a
better way to do this with Kotlin
there's an automatic approach that takes
exactly one line of code isn't that much
better to use say bye lazy will set it
to 574 so it doesn't get set to anything
until someone asked for the first time
and then it goes through some operations
to actually allocate and return this
value of 574 and the question is what
operations does it go through so I
should explain first lazy is implemented
using property delegates in Kotlin and
it's at this generic mechanism they have
for delegating logic somewhere else so I
want when someone asks for this variable
I want you to run this logic over here
and return other information from there
the other background piece of
information is properties properties in
Kotlin do much more than properties in
the java programming language which
means if you're going to access
information on a property using
reflection well how does that work
through the bytecode since Java
programming language doesn't have that
capability
all right well colin needed to add
capabilities so that when you use a
reflection it will go through there
extra or additional stuff to actually
get that extra bit of information from
their property so they created this
class called kay property and now if you
use reflection on a colin property it
can go through the kay property and get
that extra information that it needs so
that's the background here's what's
going on inside of lazy first of all
when you say by lazy it automatically
creates an array allocation brain should
say oh there's a now
ocation so you've got this K property
array where it's going to set up the
information for getting things from this
Kotlin specific property reflection
mechanism that they have so we've got
the array and the array consists of one
item which is this K property that
they've set up specifically for this
lazy property that you've told it about
you've got the class name you've got the
type and that's basically it you've got
the name of the thing right so it sets
this up
array plus an allocation of the K
property inside of it then it sets up
this call internally this is sort of
initialization time code it says okay
there's this lazy thing that's going to
return a class of type lazy and from
that we can get the value so when you
call together on that property it's
going to call into this code which is
going to call a get value on that lazy
object and then it's going to call in
value on that all of this could bottom
out in reflection code to go get it from
K property which is like even worse than
the allocations we've seen so far like
at at the end of all of this you may end
up in reflection code just to get an
integer value however because of
extension methods they're more clever
than that and they actually spit out
this extension method that says oh if
it's a lazy thing if they're using the
lazy class then we're just going to call
this function instead so no need for
reflection even though K property stuff
was set up and has reflection
capabilities we're not using that aspect
of it instead it'll just call into this
method and get the value which is this
simpler than reflection however a couple
of conditions to check and a
synchronized Block in there just to get
this int value from this very stupid
example I've written in addition to that
when all of this is set up we go through
initialization code which in bytecode
looks something like this so basically
whenever you get into this and
initialize this object this is what gets
emitted on your behalf under the hood
just to save an allocation of an integer
object as I said stupid example but real
example is people doing it for small
data structures like rep so lazy is
awesome it's really cool that you can do
this in one line of code and if you have
a complicated data structure or a lot of
complicated object when it gets set up
and if it's not going to be used very
often
totally worth considering for avoiding
the allocation of a simple int
why not so now let's take a look at
unsigned numbers so this is a new
experimental features that was
introduced in curtain 1.3 so Java has
mostly signed numbers and kirtland is
finally bringing unsigned numbers which
can be very useful when you do graphics
code for instance when you have a width
and a height you want them to be
unsigned it's very useful as you know as
a type check that you're not going to
get a negative value which will make no
sense for dimension so if you enable
this experimental feature here's how you
can use the unsigned numbers you can use
the U suffix to declare a type to be
unsigned and under the hood they are
implemented using another experimental
feature called inline classes and we're
going to take a closer look at the nine
classes in a little bit but first let's
take a look at this example so I declare
two unsigned numbers and then then and
then I just add them so what happens so
every unsigned number is just an integer
that's pushed on the stack and store in
a variable so here there's nothing
interesting to see and when we add them
we just load those two variables we call
the I add operation code embed code
which is just the addition of two
integers which are normally sign but gel
rounds that were very clever and they
realized that because of the way that
sine numbers and signed integers are
encoded it actually works with unsigned
as well so they didn't have to create
any anything new you can just use the
existing byte code everything happens at
the language level the only thing that
so do bizarre here is that we invoke a
static function called you int that
constructor - in pole you can see that
it takes an integer and returns an
integer so if we look at this particular
function to see what it does that's
where things get a real surprising and
I'm sure the JetBrains folks we know why
it does this I have no idea so we have
this function takes an integer returns
an integer and here's the implementation
it loads the parameter that you give it
and then it returns it and that's it so
I don't know why why it's there it's
maybe for the debugger so you can break
on it but other than that you know I
know the digits or the ahead of time
compiler will get rid of it or probably
all right so you don't need to worry
about this it's just a little strange
that we have this extra byte code for no
reason
so if you look at the other operators we
saw that the addition is just
implemented with the existing opcode add
same thing for the subtraction something
with the multiplication it's only when
you do a division that Katrina has to
invoke a special static method because
the dajun's works differently so there's
more code that runs here so most of the
time you know the unsigned numbers are
basically free so if you should feel
free to use them now let's look at what
happens when you try to print one of
those numbers basically when you try to
call to string on it so here I have a
signed number and an unsigned number and
I print them both so first let's look at
the sign number so we have this variable
called Z is equal to 42 and we call
println on it so that's exactly what we
expect but when we use the unsigned
number instead of printing it directly
because the default print a line in the
run time does not know about unsigned
numbers we have to go through something
else
and because the unsigned numbers are
implemented using in line classes we
have to box so because call this
function called box - in pole it takes
our unsigned integers and wrap it into
an instance of a class called EWTN's and
that gets passed to println because you
int has a two string method that's
implementing and then there's the right
thing so even if you use unsigned
numbers and there are most of the time
free you can end up doing boxing and
therefore allocation fairly easily if
you just add them to a string for
instance talk about ranges one of the
curious things that a lot of programmers
hit when they see Colin for the first
time is - for loops they kind of look
for the syntax that they always knew
from Java or C or C++ or other languages
and it's not that instead all of the for
loops work with ranges and there are
many ways to do this so you could say
for I in this range of 0 to 10 inclusive
or exclusive until you get to 10 or you
could just say repeat the following
operation give it the lambda there or
you could put the range on the front
these all look the same to me modulo
that off by one error that we have in
the second one right so it turns out
they're kind of different under the hood
so that first one works the way that we
would think it's basically equivalent of
the for loop we would expect in Java
second ones same thing except we're not
going all the way to the last value
there
same thing for the third like all
straightforward iterations but the way
the last one is implemented is a little
different instead we're gonna create an
iterable object we're gonna create an in
range object and then we're gonna use
the iteration mechanism which seems a
little bit heavyweight for just having
flips the range to the front they're not
a big deal but kind of curious that
they're all quite different under the
hood yes so in the traditional for loop
with other languages you can easily
increment the counter by more than one
so doing plus plus you can say plus
equal to and the way you do this in
cutting is you can use the step operator
or in fixed function so in that case
we're going to go from 0 to 10 inclusive
and we inclusive and we want it to
increment by 2 it says step through and
I would expect the code to look exactly
the same as before but we get this
instead so just by adding step an
optimization the compiler basically
disappears and said we have to create a
range we have to create this in
progression and then the compiler calls
get first get less and get step which
are in dispatcher paste constant so it's
not entirely necessary and then we have
a while loop that makes sure that we
iterate the right number of times and it
also happens if you said step 1
which makes no sense to me without
zooming so missing optimization in the
compiler that first step is a doozy
right so in nine classes I touched on
those a little bit when I talked about
unsigned numbers so in line classes are
where to wrap a type one field
effectively and the point of needing
classes as the name suggests is that the
disappear at compile time we saw that
with unsigned numbers there are class
called EWTN's but really when you look
at the bytecode all you see in the end
is just an integer so here I created my
own in nine class called color and it
could it writes it perhaps an integer
because colors are often defined as an
integer on Android and I've created
custom properties to be able to extract
the right green blue and alpha channels
from the int without having to do that
that dense myself every time so now if
you try to use that that inline class
ourselves I created a print function
that just you know formats a string
using the different channels of the
color create an instance at the bottom
in my main function I call the print the
print collection I just declare and
the bytecode looks like in the main
function so first we push a consent on
the stack is that weird long number that
comes corresponds to the hexadecimal
value that you saw in the code and then
we invoke that color that constructor -
import function and you can see it's
signature it takes an int which is
expected because we wrap an integer and
it returns an integer so it's exactly
what was happening with unsigned before
we saw that this constructor actually
doesn't do anything just text the input
and returns it directly so there's
nothing to see here what's interesting
is what happened to my print color
function so in my source code it takes
the color instance but you can see here
now it's called print color - some weird
name it's a it's probably a hash of
something instead of taking an instance
of color it takes an integer directly so
the compiler rewrote the function to
work to work dark beyond the primitive
type type I was rapping that said
sometimes in our classes are not free we
saw that with two string earlier and the
same thing can happen with the equal
equal operator so here are create two
instances of my color class and I just
called you know I want to print whether
or not they are equal and I do it in two
different ways first we use equal equal
and then we do dot equals and those
should be equivalent there should be the
same thing however when we look at the
bytecode here's what happens so when I
do a equal equals B first we load one of
the variables
I think it's B then we call boxed at -
in pole and you can see that we are
generating a color instance from that
integer then we do the same thing again
for the a variable and then finally we
invoke a static function called are
equal that's part of that that's an
intrinsic in the cut in standard library
so just to be able to compare our two
integers that we know are there because
we saw that the compiler sometimes it's
smart enough to get rid of the class we
just boxed it back into actual objects
we created two allocations just to be
able to compare those two integer values
if you call a dot equals B things are a
little different
we load one of the variables and we
bucks the other one so instead of in two
locations we have only one allocation
and instead here we're calling a method
called equals - in pull on the color
class and you can see takes an integer
and an object so if you're gonna use the
nine classes and you don't care about in
a liability
in the doctor in Central Connecticut
half as many objects if you say a dot
equals B instead of a equals equals me
take a quick look at arrays the
implementation depends very much on
little subtle differences in how you
declare things so here we're gonna call
int array of and we pass in these things
and it's gonna say yep here's a
primitive array that contains those
things or we could say array of and
we're gonna pass these things and we
know that Kotlin is really good at type
inference and these are obviously int
and it says yep here's your integer
array or we could say give me an int
array and actually ask for this thing
specifically and then it does the right
thing with a little bit more code
we're basically initializing it inside
the lambda there and it creates the
primitive int array to whip through that
alright so we'd land us there's a one
party release case that can be
definitely of tricky and we just
recorded the podcast this morning with
the pocket casts folks and tour mention
that you just like that
yeah so what you're gonna see is a
possible programming mistake thankfully
we have a lint check in androids view
that wants you against it so here's a
for instance a class written in the Java
programming language it's a widget of
some kind and you can register listener
so we have this interface it has a
single abstract method - Sam you can add
a listener you can remove the listener
and you can ask how many listeners are
registered now let's try to use this fun
cutting so first of all we instantiate
our widgets then I create my listener as
well lambda and it follows the if we go
back our single abstract method taxi
widget instance as a parameter so we
create a lambda that matches this
signature text text widget and then we
do something with it we print it then I
call add listener on my widget and I
print the number of listeners that are
registered and finally I try to remove
that listener and a print the number of
listeners that are registered what's
gonna happen is sorry let me do yeah so
what's gonna happen is that when we
print the number of listeners after
adding it it's gonna set this one inner
that's completely expected but after
calling remove the number of listeners
is still 1
to remove did not work and to understand
why doesn't work we have to look at the
code that's generated by the compiler so
here's what it looks like we create our
listener because it's a lambda it
becomes a function one type internally
and a function one is effectively your
lambda that has one parameter but
because that that type is function one
it is not the listener type data which
it expects so the compiler generates
this extra class called widget
underscore listener that is of the type
listener that we expect and it passes it
our function one our lambda so it wraps
it into something else and it's that
other object that gets passed to add
listener and you can probably guess
what's coming up next when we could
remove listener with our lambda it gets
wrapped again it's a different instance
so we're trying to remove a different
listener and so we actually leaked our
listener and this is the kind of stuff
that Android Co will warn you against
and the fix is fairly easy you just have
to be specific about the type of your
lambda just say it is a widget that
listener and don't just use the naked
lambda form so let's take a look at how
extension functions actually work under
the hood so you have this simple class
that I've defined again I wrote this
code all by myself we have a superclass
and then we have a subclass which
extends that superclass awesome then we
have a couple of extension methods that
we've defined one on the superclass one
of the subclass and they print out this
value or they return the string value
that indicates which one was actually
called so the super instance we say yep
give me one of those super class objects
subclass give me one of those subclass
objects and then we have one where it is
a subclass but we cast it to a
superclass and then the question is what
happens when we call get identifier on
each of these things and then we have
one more example where instead of
precasting it we're casting it at run
time to a superclass so the question is
when we call the get identifier on the
super Val we get anybody awake
there we go what a super answer all
right how about the next one all right
thank you and number three wrong sorry
super so this is the one that's a little
bit surprising and finally the last one
is the same so it is a subclass what is
actually going on like shouldn't it be
calling that method on the subclass it's
because of these the implementation of
these things so if we look at the
decompiled bytecode this is what we've
got
get identifier is now a static method
and it takes an instance of superclass
same thing for sub the get identifier on
the subclass object so that means that
when we call it with a superclass object
we end up in the one that takes a
superclass type
same thing for sub and same thing for
sub cast as super we have told the type
system this is a superclass no matter
how we actually created it so it's going
to call the get identifier that takes a
superclass instead and same thing for
the thing that's passed at runtime
default parameters it's a very handy
function in Kirkland you can specify a
default value for your parameters and
then you can use either name parameters
to invoke them or just omit the
parameters and rely on the compiler to
do the right thing so here I have a very
useful method it takes two floats and
you just adds them and returns the
results where did the rest of the
oh sorry wrong sighs all right so here's
the code that get generated so from that
code that we have that takes default
parameter values we have a new static
function that was created that the
stakes are two floats without default
values because no we generated bytecode
and just returns it just adds them and
returns the result but here's there's
another method that was created so it
takes two floats as we expect and then
it also takes an integer and an object
as far as I can tell the object is
always said to know so I'm natural white
stairs probably to tag those methods in
a way or another I should I straight
brains they will probably know the
answer and the integer is actually a big
field where every bit tells the method
which parameters you did not specify at
the call site so you can see here when
we check the first bit
two and one if it's set that means that
we did not specify a value so we use the
default value that we specified on the
cutting side and then we do this for
every parameters parameter and at the
end we invoke the actual function that's
at the top
what's interesting because it's an
integer I was wondering you know there's
only 32 bits so what happens when you
have 33 parameters and we're going to
take a look at that in a moment
but just here are some examples of how
it works so if I called my function
directly without specific specifically
any values the curtain compiler would
just use the default value 0 and then
for the bit field it will set 3 so the
bit 1 and 2 are set and it's going to
use the default values if I specify the
first parameter we see our value as the
first parameter which is 0 for the
second one the bid field is set to 2
because the second parameter is not set
same thing when you specify only the
second parameter and then of course if
you specify the two parameters we call
directly the function that does the
actual work and we skip all those checks
so we have only 32 bits what happened we
will create a function that has 33
parameters you should probably not do
that in your code but just in case that
double check for you what happened
honestly I was waiting for I was
expecting the compiler to just send up
too many parameters I can do that what
it does it creates two integers so it
just adds a second bit field and going
to look at the bits in both bit fields
because what's better than a bit field
two bit fields all right finally
co-routines we only have three minutes
left so we're gonna go through this very
quickly how many of you use co-routines
okay so sorry for the for those of you
who don't know how proteins work without
I'm gonna gonna explain that too much
but basically so you have a suspend
function that means you can do heavy
work in there and here I call a function
called delay we're simulating heavy work
then I'll launch a curve routine so we
print that I'm launching a curry team
then I call launch I call my suspend
function twice so compute and compute
and finally I print exiting crow routine
so if we don't run this program we're
gonna see the following output
relaunching the recording we're
computing that our suspend function
we're computing again that's our suspend
function wigs it's curtains are
implemented using state machines so if
you look at the code that's generated
it's gonna look something like this
there's going to be
vogue suspend function generates
somewhere in at the top does a switch on
an intro field so that function is
inside the class and it switches on the
field code label and ylabel is basically
where you are in the current state
machine so every suspend function you
call in the core routine will be a state
in a state machine so here you can see
we switch on label and in the case 0 we
set the label to 1 that means we advance
to the next state and we call our first
instance of the compute function when
those suspend functions return a magic
value called suspended we return from
the state machine that means that the
core routine has to be paused and will
have to come back later when we cannot
resume execution and again if you look
at the other state so when the state is
1 we advance the state to 2 we call
compute sorry we call computer set a
second time in a return if you're
suspended so what I did is I took the
bytecode of that and the bytecode starts
like this and I hacked it to add this
you don't need to understand what it's
doing but basically all I wanted to do
was print the current state of the of
the coding of the state machine and
rerun the program to see what's going on
so this was the original output and when
I print this label field this is what it
looks like
so we launch the Karoo teen we enter
that state machine the state is 0 we
call compute our first suspend function
where we return because we're suspended
and then at some point later we re-enter
the state machine now the state is 1
when we compute we return again we come
back into the state machine with the
live state and the finally we exit the
origin so again you shouldn't worry not
worry about this too much in your code
use co-routines they are amazing it was
very interesting to go look at the byte
code at the generate code to better
understand how they work how old that
what looks magical how it works under
the hood and with that you have 30
seconds Chet so wrap up so the question
is should you actually care about this
stuff we've given a couple of talks in
the last couple of years and said you
know what the run time has gotten so
much better stop worrying about all the
allocation and de-allocation stuff we
told you early days of Android avoid
allocations now do the right thing for
your code in your API so the question is
did we lie to you and the answer is no
actually we were telling the truth that
is still good advice however oh yeah and
there's the advice yep yep alakay
and Collections always fine but it's
good to actually understand what's going
on in the hood if you are trying to be
lazy about allocating even a rect object
that's not the right approach right it
probably doesn't matter but isn't it
nice to actually know what's going on
and especially if you're in an inner
loop somewhere maybe you actually don't
want that overhead maybe it doesn't
matter on the other hand if you can save
it in a case where it actually matters
in an inner loop that's probably a good
thing and that is it thank you
[Music]
you